we know next to nothing about elden ring
but that won't stop me and the game spot
staff from listing off some things we'd
love to see in from software's next
outing well i guess i should back up a
little you might know something
but we are going to pretend like that
little leak never happened just to make
it crystal clear
i won't be commenting on the leak or
showing any elden ring gameplay
footage so if you're worried about
spoilers you can rest
easy if you want to see more videos like
this make sure to subscribe and like the
video
it really does help us out
number one world diversity at this point
from software has shown it can execute
spectacularly on different flavors of
fantasy whether it's the medieval vibes
of demon souls and dark souls the cosmic
horror of bloodborne or the sengoku
samurai era of sakura
eldon ring is the studio's first open
world game
and naturally i expect it to be much
grander in scope
the so-called elden ring that has been
shattered is described as something that
commanded the stars and its destruction
burned the sky it would be fascinating
to see the impact this has on numerous
different kinds of societies and
civilizations
in game that would mean being able to
travel from one kingdom to the next
effectively letting from software flex
its creative muscles with a variety of
different themes and aesthetics
using the studio's existing games
imagine traveling from lordran to
yharnam and then to drangleic or
bulletaria and then to ashina
sure it's ambitious but if anyone can
pull it off it's from
software couple that with game of
thrones writer george r martin being
involved in the creation of eldon ring
and you've got a good opportunity to
deliver a vast and diverse world rich in
detail
intricate history and fascinating lore
[Music]
number two a dangerous open world all
that said i've been having a lot of
trouble wrapping my head
around an open world souls-like game i'm
confident it can
work i just don't know how it will work
the maze-like interconnected passageways
have long been a staple of the series
designing an open world game is another
beast entirely will the entire world be
open to you from the get-go
if so how will it be balanced will some
sections of the map be too tough for you
early on or will enemies scale with you
as you level up will some areas be shut
off entirely or will they be gated by
environmental hazards akin to death
mountain and the legend of zelda breath
of the wild either way
the world needs to feel dangerous and
alive no matter where you are
in it number three with caves and
dungeons to explore while i'm excited to
see what from software does with an open
world i hope i still get slices of their
brilliant linear level design
if we do i imagine this will come in the
form of caves
dungeons and castles the player is free
to explore
i want to hop on my horse ride until i
see an abandoned castle
and explore a tightly crafted dungeon
with worthwhile loot
tough enemies and of course a terrifying
boss
number four puzzles speaking of caves
and dungeons hidetaka miyazaki wears his
influences on his sleeve and he is known
to be a big fan
of the legend of zelda franchise in his
own words the franchise was a monumental
part of his younger life and has
acknowledged that zelda became a
textbook for the 3d action games
it would be great to see miyazaki pull
more directly from nintendo's franchise
specifically breath of the wild shrines
outside of gimmick bosses
traditional puzzle solving hasn't been a
big part of from software's games
and although it doesn't need to be the
main focus i would love to see from
software invite the player to think in
different ways in one of their games
perhaps in elden ring the challenges
don't just have to be powerful enemies
but could also include puzzles that can
only be surmounted with analysis and
logical thinking the open world will no
doubt be filled with caves dungeons and
other nooks and crannies to explore and
they'd be perfect for a bit of puzzle
gameplay
number 5 class based design i loved
sekiro
hell it might even be one of my favorite
games of this generation
however i think i speak for most of us
when i say that i miss the class system
found in demon cells dark souls and
bloodborne
if eldon ring is from software's first
open world game a class and leveling
system would feel right at home
i want to be able to test out different
builds level up unique weapons and
create my perfect hero for whatever
terrifying bosses i might face off
against
hopefully from software we'll also
introduce some classes unique to the
world miyazaki and martin have created
i always loved how bloodborne's classes
were wholly unique to its setting and i
hope we get some outlandish builds i can
play around with
or just let me be giant dad again
number six better stealth let's face it
the stealth in dark souls and bloodborne
has always been a bit
awkward and a tad broken
they did a better job of balancing it
over the years but stealth never really
felt like a viable option this changed
with 2019 sekiro shadows die twice
surprisingly the addition of stealth
mechanics didn't make it any easier
either you could even stealth attack
some bosses
but if you didn't have a good grasp of
the combat itself the boss would make
short work of you for elden ring i hope
that stealth becomes a more feasible
option whether that means giving us a
dedicated crouch button or an entire
stealth attribute i can invest in
is another story the key here though is
to balance it i wouldn't want it to feel
cheesy or significantly easier than
other play styles though magic based
gameplay has been present
in some form or another in every souls
game it's never been outstanding in any
demon souls is often remembered as
having the best magic mechanics but
that's usually because it's incredibly
overpowered
not only could you pick off enemies from
a distance with ease but mp restoration
items were common this allowed for a
wide variety of magic
builds that could easily break the
balance in every subsequent souls game
the magic system was reworked entirely
dark souls 3 borrowed a lot from demon
souls magic based mechanics but
none have been as fun or as interesting
as the original demon soul system
hopefully the success of the remake
means from software will take another
look at its magic system
who knows maybe they're cooking up
something else entirely for magic
number eight towns and more npcs one of
my
favorite things about dark souls
bloodborne and sekiro are the memorable
npcs
like many of you i cling on to nearly
every word they say
listening for hints secrets and bits of
lore however
npcs can be scarce some can even be
missed
entirely if you aren't paying attention
i would be really curious to see what
from software would do with a town
populated by npcs
demon souls dark souls and bloodborne
all took place after a catastrophic
event that left most the population
either dead
or hiding hopefully elden ring will show
us a world slightly more alive than
before
also i'm thinking it you're thinking it
we're all thinking it but what role will
patches play in elden ring
sound off in the comments below with
your theories
number 9 dragon rider from software
seems to have a bit of an antagonistic
relationship with dragons and by
extension the players of its games end
up having that too
the mythical beasts are a mainstay in
most of its games and for the most part
players
are either jabbing swords into their
hides
or running frantically away from them as
they fuse spire in our direction
usually on some sort of bridge unless of
course it's that no-good betrayer seat
the scaleless then they're running
frantically away from ice crystals
i think it's time to rewrite that
relationship a bit and let players
befriend a dragon
people have been making a big deal about
elden ring having horse mounted
traversal but why not go one step
further from software let us ride a
dragon
it doesn't have to be all the time and
it doesn't even have to be with our
direct control
maybe there's a kingdom of dragons on
the outskirts of the world and if you
wanted to travel across the land mass
quickly they'd let you take a dragon
as opposed to directly controlling the
beast it could be kind of like world of
warcraft's fast travel system where you
just watch the dragon fly over the
entire world and it just drops you where
you want
then like world of warcraft they could
update the game so that you could play
peggle while on the dragon
on second thought maybe no peggle
especially if it's that wretched peggle
blast
[Music]
number 10 intricate and obtuse lore for
many
the story and lore of the soulsborne
games are the highlights
while some might consider the plots
themselves to be simple there is an
endless amount of backstory to dig into
any one of these games
sekuro on the other hand is a bit of an
exception while there still is a ton of
interesting lore it puts a
greater emphasis on the plot now this
isn't a bad thing by any stretch but
part of the reason why dark souls
bloodborne and demon souls are so
memorable is how
obtuse everything was not only did you
have to work hard to beat bosses but you
had to work hard to unpack the story for
eldon ring i hope from software manages
to find a rewarding balance between an
interesting plot and an intricate and
deep
world those are just a few things
i'd love to see in elden ring let us
know what you think in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to subscribe thanks all and
i will see you next time
[Music]
you